انظروا لقد رأيتم بعضاً من تلك المشاعر عندما
غادر قاعة المحكمة وهذا ما كان
يحدث داخل قاعة المحكمة وكذلك
الدموع والهتافات تتصاعد حيث
قرر القاضي إبطال عقوبة السجن المؤبد
ضد عدنان سيد كان في
قاعة المحكمة تلك الجلسة استمرت أه حوالي
عامين  ساعة مع استراحة مدتها 30 دقيقة
بين هذا الوقت كان
المدعون العامون قادرين على تقديم
الدليل الذي قدموه في
أدلة حركتهم التي تم الحصول عليها من
إعادة التحقيق لمدة عام في القضية
التي ركزت حقًا على هذا
المطوَّر حديثًا  معلومات حول
مشتبهين بديلين وأيضًا
إخفاق الدولة كما قال المدعون
في مشاركة بعض تلك
المعلومات الموجودة حول مشتبهين بديلين
مع الدفاع في
وقت المحاكمة ، ويبدو أن هذه الحجة
كافية لإقناع القاضي لإلغاء الحكم
أثناء  جلسة الاستماع التي سمعناها أيضًا من
عائلة Heyman Lee قام شقيقها
بالتكبير للتحدث نيابة عن العائلة
لتذكير من هم في قاعة المحكمة
هذا ليس بودكاست بالنسبة له ، فهذه
هي الحياة الواقعية بشكل جيد ، لقد سمعنا من
المدعين بمجرد صدور
قرار أمم بإلغاء العقوبة ،
سمعنا أيضًا من
محام يمثل عائلة لي الذي
قال هذا.
تهتم الأسرة بالسعي لتحقيق العدالة ،
فهم يريدون أن يعرفوا أكثر من أي
شخص قتل Heyman Lee Jake ،
لذا ينتظر المدعون العامون
تقرير ما إذا كانوا سيُسقطون
التهم حتى يحصلوا على نتائج
اختبار الحمض النووي ، ماذا نعرف  حول هذا
الحق لذا فهم يوضحون
أن هذا ليس إعلانًا عن
إيمانهم ببراءته يقولون إن
هذه فرصة للمضي قدمًا
في التحقيق يريدون
ضمان تحقيق العدالة وأن
هناك تمثيل مناسب أه  بالنسبة إلى
عدنان سيد ، إذا كانت هناك تجربة مستقبلية ،
فإنهم يقولون فقط إن قرار
الذهاب إلى المحاكمة سيعتمد الآن على
نتائج الحمض النووي المعلقة التي يقومون باختبارها باللمس
للحمض النووي ، وهذا نوع  من الاختبارات التي
لم تكن متاحة في الوقت الذي
أدين فيه سيد ، لذا فهم يحاولون
التعجيل بالنتائج هناك لمعرفة ما
يمكنهم الحصول عليه من هذه النتائج قبل
اتخاذ قرار بشأن الذهاب إلى المحاكمة الجديدة
أو رفض التهم تمامًا ، رأينا
عدنان سيد يغادر  قاعة المحكمة اليوم
أعتقد أن ارتداء جهاز مراقبة الكاحل ما هو
التالي بالنسبة له ، نعم سيكون تحت
المراقبة المنزلية الإلكترونية أثناء
استمرار التحقيق
وحتى يتم اتخاذ قرار بشأن ما إذا كان سيتم
رفض التهم أو المضي قدمًا في المحاكمة الجديدة أم لا ،
ولكن يمكنك حقًا '  التقليل من أهمية
هذا القرار أو التقليل من شأنه ،
يبدو أن الدفاع قد عمل
لأكثر من عقدين من الزمن لمحاولة استئناف
هذه الإدانة التي حافظ عليها عدنان سيد لسنوات
وسنوات على براءته
من قتل صديقته السابقة.
يجب أن نذكر
أنفسنا ليس فقط
بسبب جهود الدفاع لتبرئته أو
تبرئته ، فهذا شيء جاء
لأن الادعاء كان جزءًا من  ه
إعادة التحقيق وتقديم هذا
الاقتراح لإلغاء هذه التهم حقا
مذهلة التنمية
الأجنبية